>> The government of Canada has been one of
the primary supporters of
Haiti and the Haitian people during this earthquake
time.
It's been a very difficult time.
We've -- have our troops there.
We have two ships in Haiti from the Navy with
ships able to generate
clean water as well, which is very important.
Our Armed Forces also have clean water equipment
with them.
We have donations Canadians now, individual
Canadians that total more
than $80 million those are matching donations.
We've agreed to match those and Canadians
have been very generous in
their donations to the people of Haiti.
Also with expedited the adoption of some Haitian
children who were in
the process of being adopted by Canadian parents.
We've expedited that.
So the children have already arrived in Canada
to join their, their
adoptive parents.
We are the second largest donor of aid to
Haiti.
As Finance Minister, I was able to announce
last year that we were
forgiving our debt, the debts that are owed
by Haiti to Canada.
We did that last year.
They were eliminated as of September 2009.
And we're encouraging other countries that
still have indebtedness with
Haiti to do the same thing, that is, to forgive
their debts to the
Haitian people, who are going to have to undergo
a major time of
reconstruction, which is going to take years.
And we're going to helpful as a government
in Canada with Canadians in
support in helping the reconstruction in Haiti.